on this friday night the agonizing wait
for covid19 tests
and results we're short on lab
technicians
and the potential breakthrough that
could clear some of the backlogs
as three provinces bring in more
restrictions
a global national reality check on
ottawa's child
care plans the potential price tag and
the timeline
an ontario man accused of faking
terrorism
chilling confessions that police say
were false
and canadians in australia on life in
lockdown
i don't want to say it's prison-like
what's happening down under to keep
kobit 19
under control
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is slowly happening in parts of this
country where covid 19 cases are rising
public health restrictions are being
reimposed ontario's premier announced
new rules today that apply across the
province
effective today at midnight all bars and
restaurants
will be only permitted to remain open
until midnight all adult entertainment
clubs will be closed
right across the province and tomorrow
going forward
restaurant and bars must stop serving
alcohol
at 11 p.m and close their establishments
by midnight in manitoba the winnipeg
region is moving to code orange in its
pandemic response
starting monday masks will be mandatory
in all indoor public places
and public gatherings indoors and out
will be limited to 10 people
quebec is urging people to restrict
their social gatherings to avoid dinners
parties and barbecues for the next 28
days
that province recorded 637 new
infections today the highest daily
number
since may 21st ontario reported more
than
400 cases today for the second day in a
row there were almost 100 new cases
reported in bc and 153
in alberta more than 150 000 canadians
have now tested positive for the virus
the rate of testing has accelerated
since the spring
but as anyone who has weighted in long
lines knows
supply is not meeting demand rapid tests
could be a game changer
and this week health canada did quietly
approve a new
more rapid test that claims to deliver
results in 90 minutes
and doesn't require a lab eric sorenson
explains
as the lineups for covet 19 tests grow
in ontario
there's now a backlog of 65 000 test
samples
the highest number since the pandemic
began we can have as much testing as you
want
but if the lab is unable to process this
then you know we're no further ahead
but one new test could help with that
backlog the makers of the high-risk bee
cube
says their device has been approved by
health canada it can test through dna
for covet 19
with results in 90 minutes essentially a
test and a lab
all in one box that is portable it would
be a breakthrough for canada
this is the first point of care device
approved in canada that's truly portable
it's small you can hold it in your hand
earlier ontario's premier said he's just
waiting for new tests to help with the
backlog
just imagine if we had the rapid test to
prove that we don't have to go into the
labs
and uh because we're short on lab
technicians we maxed out the province
health canada plays a absolute critical
role in getting these approved
several types of tests are in the midst
of trials the prime minister made it
clear there will be no delays
once the science at health canada
declares them effective and safe
if and when rapid tests are approved
we're able to get them distributed
rapidly across the country
those are things that we can have ready
to go for when
an approval hits in ontario pharmacies
are now offering tests to cope with the
backlog
this woman works in a long-term care
facility it's free and it's safe and
it's good and
less lineups test results still take
time in ontario and bc
most results are back in two days quebec
reports back in one to five days and
alberta suggests allowing seven to ten
days
so new devices and other tests still in
trials
could be a big help the b cube for one
is not as accurate as those
invasive nose swabs so there would have
to be a follow-up on positive tests
but this could clear out a lot of
negative test results
this is great news uh you know we do
need to
increase tests and capacity and that
could be by adding capacity to the
current test or bringing in online
bringing online some parallel tests that
can take the burden off the
conventional lab tests the distributor
songbird life science reportedly hopes
to ramp up production to make
thousands of the bq boxes for
distribution across canada
eric sorensen global news toronto there
was no mention of that newly approved
test when prime minister justin trudeau
held a briefing this morning
the focus was on the longer term promise
of access
to a vaccine if a safe and effective one
is developed
abigail beeman reports we now have
active cases in every single province
prime minister stresses the seriousness
of a second wave as he makes new
commitments for vaccines in development
canada is buying up to 20 million doses
from astrazeneca and committing another
440 million dollars to the kovacs
facility
which pools resources and distribution
for vaccines globally
between developed and developing
countries this pandemic
can't be solved by any one country alone
because to eliminate the virus anywhere
we need to eliminate it everywhere
canada now has deals for
six vaccines in development and access
to another six through kovacs
the global market for vaccines remains
intense
and unpredictable the contractual
negotiations are complex
they're not simply a matter of
distributing a standard form contract
and having suppliers agree to our
preferred terms the federal government
is promising
safety but isn't making promises on
timelines the astrazeneca vaccine is in
phase three
but clinical trials in the u.s are still
on hold after an
unexplained illness in one participant
kovacs's goal is to provide 2 billion
doses by the end of 2021
in total between all deals canada now
has access to a guaranteed minimum of
174 million doses
and you'll remember during the height of
the first wave we saw the prime minister
give
daily covet 19 updates now facing a
second wave his office confirms to
global news we can expect to see
more of justin trudeau in the coming
days giving more coven 19
updates abigail beeman global news
ottawa
justin trudeau has a minority government
and today it got the support it appears
to need from the new democrats to
survive a confidence vote on the throne
speech the ndp tells global news
they have a deal with the liberals
including to massively expand the number
of canadians who can access
sick days one of the promises in the
throne speech is a big investment in
child care a national child care program
is
not a new idea it's just never been
delivered and lots of details are
missing from this promise like
how much will be invested and where the
money will come from
tonight michael couture has a reality
check access to more affordable
accessible and high quality and
inclusive
child care the idea of a national child
care system was first floated back in
the early 1990s now
it's the trudeau liberals turn the
minister in charge of families admits
it won't happen overnight this is
something we're committed to and
it is something that's going to take a
number of years although we are very
much committed to showing early progress
by creating additional
affordable spaces ottawa and the
provinces already agreed to an early
learning and child care framework in the
throne speech the government signaled
it would learn from quebec's model which
is considered
the gold standard according to a study
from the university of quebec in
montreal
the total cost of direct and indirect
subsidies to all types of child care in
that province last year
was 2.9 billion dollars representing
less than one percent of quebec's gdp
using those same metrics it would cost
10 billion dollars
and the same proportion of canada's gdp
for a program
covering other provinces excluding
quebec
economists point out the quebec program
pays for itself
for every hundred dollars in subsidized
care in quebec
the quebec government got 103 and 304
dollars
in new provincial income taxes hi erin
those benefits come in the form of
reintegrating women into the workforce
the one problem with the quebec system
according to those who have studied it
is that it's two-tiered non-profit uh
early childhood centers uh are uh
highly they get very high marks
uh throughout the world in terms of the
level of quality so
on the other hand the private for-profit
sector
is not as good and that's one of the
reasons why the conservatives are
against a national system
and if you're giving parents more money
back in their pockets they're better
able to choose what is best in their
situation the government says it will
study all options available but minister
hussein said we could get some of the
costing details
in the fall fiscal update mike lacouter
global news ottawa
an ontario man who claimed he had
conducted executions for the so-called
islamic state is facing
the rare charge of faking his
involvement with a terrorist group
the 25 year old has been identified by
sources as the same man who featured in
a new york times podcast called
caliphate
in that podcast he claimed he carried
out executions for isis in syria and
then
returned home to canada a free man the
rcmp now
say he made it up he's been arrested and
charged
our chief investigative correspondent
carolyn jarvis joins me from toronto
with the details caroline
donna until now he's only gone by the
alias abu husaifa but now we're able to
share his real name
sharose chowdhry a man who's been
charged with committing a terrorism
hoax and a warning some of the excerpts
from the podcast you're about to hear
are graphic and disturbing after that
i stabbed him the blood was just
it was warm and it sprayed
everywhere his gruesome detailed
confessions of
execution-style murders were heard
around the world
what are we going to call him the
canadian he wants us to call him
abu husaifa known only by his alias we
can now show you what he looks like
and share his real name sharose
chowdhury
a man from burlington ontario who's
facing a charge of committing a
terrorism
hoax meaning some or all of his grisly
account of traveling to syria
and joining the so-called islamic state
may be a lie
we put him up on a cross and
i had to leave the dagger in his heart
chowdhury caused a firestorm in ottawa
when politicians believed a terrorist
had returned to canada without arrest
canadians deserve more answers from this
government why aren't they doing
something about this
the facts in chowdhury's story changed
as he spoke with different reporters
including global news to whom he claimed
he served in isis
but didn't kill anyone i need to figure
out
is he for real the caliphate podcast
produced by the new york times
found holes in huzaifa's story but said
two officials in the u.s government as
well as an isis source confirmed he was
a member of isis
in syria if he's found guilty of
committing a terrorism hoax
chowdhury could face up to five years in
jail they will have to show that
exactly that because of the hoax that
it's creating fear that these
individuals aren't being prosecuted that
our security services can't do their
jobs
that people should fear that isis
fighters are returning and running
around
we reached out to the new york times for
comment late today but didn't hear back
by our deadline
chowdhury is scheduled to appear in
court in november
donna carolyn jarvis in toronto thanks
in paris france a stabbing that
seriously injured two people is being
treated as an act of terrorism
the victims a man and a woman worked at
a documentary production company and
they were near the former offices
of charlie hebdo two suspects have been
arrested
in 2015 12 people were gunned down when
islamic extremists targeted the office
of the french satirical newspaper
the publication had reprinted a
depiction recently of the prophet
muhammad
something many consider offensive in
islam
many americans are voting early and
eagerly
i would walk through glass and hot
charcoal and bare feet
to make this election next what's
driving people to the polls
in the u.s the late u.s supreme court
justice ruth bader ginsburg made history
again today
her flag-draped coffin was carried into
the u.s capitol where it lay in state as
mourners paid their respects
ginsburg is the first woman and the
first jewish person in american history
to be honored this way and late today
american media outlets are reporting
president trump
intends to nominate judge amy coney
barrett to fill ruth bader ginsburg's
seat on the u.s supreme court
the political battle over that seat is
one factor driving americans to the
polls
the election isn't until november 3rd
but early voting has already begun in
many states
and there are long lines at polling
stations jackson proskow went to
virginia
and found americans highly motivated to
vote
more than five weeks before the election
and this is the line for early voting in
northern virginia
i think trump's the motivating factor i
want to make sure my vote gets counted
it's been like this every day since the
polls opened
fairfax county typically sees high
turnout but nothing like this
right now we're anticipating a
90 percent turnout from fairfax county
most will vote early
in person or by mail we want to make
sure the election is honest and i'm not
sure that it can be
each time the president cast doubt about
the outcome the more people seem to rush
to the polls
there is a lot of anxiety right and
if you just do the right thing i think
the anxiety will be kind of reduced
daily developments from the pandemic to
the courts only add to the urgency
it's a very high stakes election year
and it's my first time voting
siblings steve and sally jones came here
after the sudden death of supreme court
justice ruth bader ginsburg
make sure that we grant the last wish of
ruth barrickensburg which was to not be
replaced until there's a new president
in office
this is amazing to me supporters of
president donald trump are just as
anxious about the outcome
he's done great for the country thus far
and i want him to continue to do so
some form of early voting is now
underway in more than two dozen states
nearly half of eligible voters say they
plan to vote
before november third i would walk
through glass
and hot charcoal and bare feet to make
this election
i want my country back the result is
that by election day in many counties
a majority may have already cast their
ballots leaving the candidates
little room to change minds in the final
weeks of the campaign
jackson frost go global news fairfax
county virginia
the family of brianna taylor is
demanding the release of transcripts of
the grand jury decision
not to charge any police officers
directly with her death
she was shot multiple times by police in
her own home
today her aunt read an emotional message
from the 26 year old's mother
i hope you never know the pain of your
child being murdered
191 days in a row i am angry
i am not angry for the reasons that you
would like me to be
but angry because our black women
keep dying at the hands of police
officers
at least two dozen people were arrested
last night in louisville kentucky during
another round of protests
in los angeles a protester was struck by
a pickup truck
suffering minor injuries in march
plainclothes police officers burst into
taylor's home as part of a botched drug
investigation she was shot
and killed no drugs were found her
family is leading a march through
downtown louisville tonight the mayor
has appealed for calm
pregnant princess still ahead a royal
baby announcement
canadian students from coast to coast to
coast held socially distant rallies
today they're disappointed by what they
believe is the federal government's
inaction
on climate change promises such as
curbing greenhouse gas emissions and
planting 2 billion trees september 25th
is considered a global day of action it
marks the anniversary of the 2019
global climate strike organized by
swedish activist greta tunberg
and this 18 year old british greenpeace
activist staged a protest on an ice flow
hundreds of kilometers above the arctic
circle
this year's arctic sea ice cover shrank
to the second lowest it's been since
record keeping began
four decades ago well she's not in dire
straits far from it but queen elizabeth
is facing a financial shortfall because
of the pandemic
each year the royal household opens its
accounting books to show
how it is spent public money and in part
because of a far
fewer tourists at royal palaces the bank
account will be down roughly 25 million
dollars over the next three years
buckingham palace has already put a
freeze on staff pay
and on new hiring and is looking for
other ways to cut costs
and one of the queen's granddaughters
princess eugenie has announced she's
expecting a baby
she and her husband were married two
years ago in the chapel on the grounds
of windsor castle
their child due in early 2021 will be
the queen's ninth
great-grandchild the world's strictest
lockdown next
lessons from canadians under curfew in
australia
it's just a sad fact that we're all
going to be living with this pandemic
for some time to come
the best we can do is listen to the
public health advice and
observe how other countries have handled
their outbreaks
australia had to put another strict
lockdown in place in melbourne
our mike derle spoke to some canadians
living down under
about the lessons learned it's after
melbourne's 9 pm
curfew and nerius soul is to be seen
proof what are being called the most
draconian coveted 19 measures in the
world
seem to be working 75 percent of
australia's 26
000 covet 19 cases have occurred in
victoria
state where melbourne is the capital in
late june a second wave forced the
government to take drastic action
so canadian expats like daniela
minicucci had to give up freedom of
movement
well we're not able to go further than
five kilometers unless
you're breaking the rules which of
course we're not she'd love it nothing
more than to go to the beach
but it's just outside her travel zone
residents
can go outside for two hours a day but
that's it
melbourne is so locked down it's become
an island
in an island country
[Applause]
protests were also deemed illegal but
when melbournians tried anyway
police were there to arrest them
epidemiologists say canadians should
take
note especially if numbers continue to
rise in ontario
and quebec it may come to that but let's
try and avoid that
by hanging on to the faith hope and
charity of the distancing
masking and hat hygiene we spoke with
another canadian living in australia
alex newman five days after leaving
melbourne for a new job in sydney i
opened this for too long
let's see okay so there we go
that is that is the lunch sydney isn't
taking risks with anybody coming from
the hot zone
so newman has to quarantine in a hotel
room where the windows don't open
and there's a guard on every floor so i
have a
roast beef sandwich he has to pay for
the room
the government supplies the food and it
doesn't always seem like a fair deal
i don't want to say it's prison like
because you know i have a
decent room some light and a bed but it
i can't help it feel like
a little prison like it hasn't been easy
but newman and mini coochie
are trying to stay positive in their
adoptive country
it's you just i mean what can you do
like
if the alternative is a situation like
america
no thanks so they're riding out the
storm the payoff hopefully
is an australian summer without any
covet 19 worries
mike drewlay global news toronto
and that is global national for this
friday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada
is this beautiful autumn scene in
bonneville alberta we'd love to see your
canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye
[Music]
you